right now another case we want to take a
look at fascinating case let's say you
just got out of prison you're in prison
for fraud you pick up the phone your
daughter's going to Sarah Lawrence hey
honey I got no place to go I got no
place to live can I come hang out and
bunk with you and your co-ed roomies
sure Dad uh that's kind of the way it
all started convicted sexual predator
Larry Ray sentenced today for abusing a
group of Sarah Lawrence College students
his daughter's friends it was a cult
that lasted nearly a decade he was
convicted in federal court on charges
including racketeering which we've been
talking about today conspiracy extortion
sex trafficking all kinds of stuff right
now I have with me long crime reporter
Adam klasfeld Adam you've been following
this case for a while I'm going to let
you uh lay out the lead here what
happened in court what was this guy
sentenced to
Larry Ray was sentenced to 60 years in
prisonment he is 63 years old so that is
effectively a light sentence for him and
it was for crimes that in the judge's
description were evil that were acts of
unspeakable cruelty and we heard about
those Acts and saw them throughout the
trial in reams of videos uh audio
evidence uh three of his victims spoke
to in person one through a
representative and they described just
some of the horrific abuse that they
lived through whether one of them Daniel
Levin had his testicles squeezed with a
Garrett another one was uh punched in
the stomach with a sledgehammer a same
victim Daniel Levin and Larry Ray used a
set of pliers to pull his tongue another
victim who didn't appear in court
because she wanted to move on with her
life was Larry Ray's sex trafficking
victim Claudia Drury saying that she'd
spent years in a nearly catatonic state
that she was sex trafficked by Larry Ray
to the tune of 2.5 million dollars and
spent years essentially
and delivering very moving statements
through her representative I mentioned
Daniel 11 earlier he teared up
frequently during his remarks detailing
what he lived through uh folks might be
aware of him through a memoir that he
wrote about his time in what has often
been called Larry Ray's sex cult the
book was called sloadum Woods nine named
after the communal dorm where he met and
eventually exploited his daughter's
friends and roommates there was Santos
Rosario one of three siblings who Larry
Ray victimized and he was like like his
two sisters all three attempted suicide
he talked about his feelings of being
feeling valueless feeling worthless and
how Larry Ray cultivated that to make
him feel in his debt and to make him
eventually turn over hundreds of
thousands of dollars to Larry Ray money
that he got through his mother
you know there I'm sorry let me ask you
this Adam uh because we saw the picture
producer Elizabeth we see the picture of
Larry Ray there again
um you know there's no greater evidence
of the power of persuasion and
manipulation that when you look at this
guy I mean you know yeah okay is this
guy going to convince in a normal world
uh you know co-eds to have group sex
with him and this guy is a master
manipulator and I know that you saw
evidence we saw some of the video uh
running here as you were making your
report that this guy was so egotistical
that he was taking these videos these
weren't taken by victims they were taken
by the defendant and probably because he
thought they would help him someday tell
me how that played out
well the reason why Larry Ray in his own
mind may have thought that these
horrific videos would have helped him is
because most of them are videos of quote
unquote confessions he would have the
victims confessed to ridiculous things
uh Fantastical accounts of them trying
to poison him collude with his enemies
um as a matter of fact Larry Ray himself
spoke at the sentencing hearing and the
only victim he appeared to refer to was
the one that he thought was the true
victim Larry Ray absolutely no empathy
for the victims and no sense of remorse
and I think that contributed to the fact
that the judge ultimately put him away
with for what's effectively a life
sentence so that is just one feature of
the evidence of this case it was
chronicled by him uh sometimes two
coerce the victims once you have these
videos of these quote-unquote
confessions uh they are confessing to
crimes in in their view that they think
that Larry Ray can go to the authorities
and have them on tape saying yes we
plotted against Larry Ray doing these
things and that's how he got these kids
in his thrall one of the many ways uh
other ways he would talk about his
elaborate backstory he used to be
connected to pretty powerful people
there are pictures of him with a former
Russian president Mikhail Gorbachev
there are pictures of him with former
New York city mayor Rudy Giuliani and
former NYPD Chief Bernie Carrick and he
would use these associations to create
this illusion of a very powerful man not
an ex-con who just got out of prison uh
but as a man with influence and as a man
who could have been persecuted by
shadowy powers that be and that was that
kind of image image that he pushed for
himself for his victims to keep them
under his thrall
this guy goes from couch surfing on his
daughter's dorm to to creating this
little fiefdom of his own now you see
this guy in court you mentioned what he
said that he didn't seem to have any uh
sympathy for anybody but himself but
what was his demeanor like as spending
some time in the can getting ready for
his really life sentence as you suggest
uh softened him at all did he seem
arrogant what was he like
so he gets was utterly expressionless
when the victims were speaking he was
seated behind them looked directly at
them he did not appear to be moved in
any way by anything that he was saying
the one time that he betrayed any
emotion was talking about deaths in his
own family while he was incarcerated so
it goes to what I was saying again the
only victim that Larry Ray sees here is
Larry Ray even though the world can see
all of this evidence of really and this
was again a quote from the judge
unspeakable abuse and much of it
captured on tape I have to assume he's
going to be looking around for appellate
attorneys anything you're aware of from
The Trial that may give him a foothold
on an appeal
well we'll see what happens but uh you
know there had the defense attorneys
haven't released signaled uh any plans
of attack but like you noted a little
bit earlier there is an just they're
just scores of documents videos audio
tapes just mountains of evidence all
under Larry Ray's opinion so it's very
safe to say that he has a very hard Road
uh and maybe insurmountable road to hoe
wow so Adam classfeld the managing
editor of lawcrime.com if you haven't
read Adam's stuff go to lawncrime.com
check it out uh he and his colleagues
there do fabulous work every day and
Adam I appreciate you joining today to
give us the update on this this guy
thank you for having me you bet